are you ready let's go which like this
easier to work out like a shoelace I'm
after which one's easier the vertical
one clearly right it's made of two parts
that bit which is egg unit up and that
bit which is a fee squared units down
you came with that so let's give that
thing your name what should we call it
should we call it a thief attention will
be good as well yeah it's fine
so my distance a s is equal to now that
I've called that a I suppose I could say
it's s plus 4a that's just two vertical
distance added to each other s owed by
definition is the focal length right and
this is a length so a it's just a P
squared isn't it's gone down I don't
care that it's going down all I want is
how long it is okay with that
just gonna be really nice and I'm gonna
factor happy times that's the distance
that was the easy distance because you
just had to add stuff and this distance
here it's offered an angle that's a bit
gross but no big deal I have coordinates
I've coordinates right so I'm gonna say
P s equals tell me our square root
because I've got a zero there I think
I'm gonna go to this one to this one
right so I'm going to go to a P takeaway
0 square plus AP squared take away a
swim happy with that square root of 4a
squared P squared
a squared B to the 4 minus 2 a squared B
squared because they come together plus
a square I have some white terms what
can I do with my like terms now
strategically I could do two things here
I'm gonna do them one at a time because
there's a lot of algebra flying around
strategically I'm gonna put that guy I'm
gonna make him my leading term I wonder
if you can see why they squared under
before and then these guys here are my
like tones
right before them they're going to take
away two of them there so I have two
left and there's that a squid hanging
out on the end and then a trash
suggestion I have everything divided
through by a squid okay with that so I'm
going to chuck an a out the front now
you have the tremendous advantage as I
write this next party on you have the
tremendous advantage of knowing exactly
what you are supposed to end up with so
I'm hopefully the factorization your
Batson to you is reasonably clear and
you don't have to boss around right this
is what I end up with that that distance
how do I get that out of here
that's a perfect square is it not right
and you can do a substitution if you
like and say let u equal P Square P - I
don't think like that guy at the front
is P squared squared right piece by
script so that's going to be sine equals
I've got my a at the front that's please
squared plus one squared and now as I
get rid of the square root and the
square I would usually put an absolute
value around here I usually I would do
that except I don't need to because by
definition I only need to take the
positive power okay sir just a tie up
there but that's PS which is equal to a
s therefore angle huh
what are we going to get P a s equals
angle a PS because you feel like I just
generally prefer to say equal angles
opposite equal sides because then you
can say an equilateral triangle as well
equal sides and what triangle am I
talking about done okay so I've got the
a goes they are equally inclined okay
take a deep breath
what did I do that maybe was not obvious
I had to pick out some steps in here
there were no obvious no why okay once I
get there I'm fine what would you
identify to like okay I'm lying in bed
that was a big deal right like cuz it's
a triangle and then no if I go like all
this really is kind very trivial like
you just punch it out right I would say
the second big thing is I would look
pages to get started on the question
because I had to take care and
interpretive
carefully you wouldn't believe the
number of clients that I personally and
many students I'm on jump in interpret
it wrongly and then they can't get
anywhere because their geometry is all
wrong so of course they can't prove it
right take the time getting by it would
you like me to quickly show you the next
one
I promise in so much I'm looking to any
algebra I'm just going to show it to you
that one there
because what is inclined sir is the axis
of the parabola that's the axis of
symmetry of the product which is the
y-axis so when we say x axis that's
that's what we be like axis of symmetry
of the problem say okay let's let's dig
into this some disaster of a question
yes so like I said this is a bit of a
naughty question another one of its
justifications
okay let's really quickly I promise no
no writing I'm just going to draw some
lines extra lines look at the next one
okay you can see that a cross-section
through a parabolic reflector pause what
okay a parabolic reflector is what
everyone has at least four of probably
six or more in their car then the lights
in all of your arm in all of your like
like you know in in headlights right
there actually if you look really close
there's just a single bulb there right
but what the shape of it inside is you
if you go in right it's actually a
parabolic curve right the reason why is
because that little pinprick of light it
reflects off all these other ones and
comes up to you so that's why it looks
so bright one single light it comes out
a hundred ways okay so they say a
cross-section through a parabolic
reflector it's just a fancy way of
saying a parabola
you take that beam and you slice across
it and he's your shape they even tell
you that as even example to okay so he's
the shape I'm looking a ray of light LP
I already have P upon my diagrams right
so L is going to be coming from
somewhere else and it's parallel to the
y-axis okay so it's coming in like so
this L and this P Harlin off the wire
just happy so far it makes the surface
of the problem at pain and is reflected
in relation to the tangents so yes in
other words it traces out this hot L
then P then is that's what this
parabolic reflector will do and
therefore by extension if you had this
life here does the opposite okay so
you've got this and it shines out and
everything is going to no matter where
it hits the reflector it'll all go
upwards okay by the way a quick note if
any of you have seen like a gigantic
radio telescope and they look like this
like that's okay yeah physics these
things are huge and they're in the shape
of a parabola right all of these radio
waves coming in through space they come
from all directions and because it's a
parabola no matter where they hit on the
surface they all bounced back up to that
receiver it's incredible okay that's the
situation it's what these IKEA keep
reading sure that the angle of incidence
equals the angle of reflection what on
earth is any of that now if you recall I
told you I didn't do physics so I have
no idea what an angle of incidence is so
why wait I looked it up okay this is
back in the day when I first met this
question okay what's it talking about
you guys correct me if I'm wrong okay
what you need is he is my light coming
in it reflects off the surface okay
simplifying this a little bit okay
here's a beer of light and reflect off
the surface okay
the angle of incidence I believe is this
guy right so what you put in there is a
line perpendicular to your surface
perpendicular to your surface we have a
name for this thing it's called that's
normal right so you have a normal here
so there's some angle here theta that's
the angle of incidence wave hit okay
and then the angle of reflection again
correct me if I'm wrong I think is this
guy right it's the angle at which you
reflect away okay
so where is that on here I take the
normal which conveniently since I have a
tangent here it's going to be off like
that at a slight angle where is my angle
of incidence it's going to be coming in
and there it is right there I'm gonna
call that guy my name of incidence
where's my angle of reflection it's
right next to it they're adjacent so
should be here so what I want is for
alpha and beta to be the same okay now I
promise it's really actually quite
simple
based on the part we just did okay door
forgets
don't forget lines they're parallel
right by definition they're parallel
when you have parallel lines tell me
something about angles on parallel lines
you've got as an angle she got
correspond to use you have no interior
angles which ones are gonna be most
useful to me yeah I think corresponding
ones are gonna be the most useful now
the colors are started gonna be intense
I get it usually rejoins a diagram for
this but watch these strengths you
remember we proved in the previous part
that these two at the same time Michaela
that so now I'm going to use my double
line if this admissible I also know that
this is equal to this because I have
parallel lines and one tangent that axes
the transversal across corresponding
correspondence do you see any way a lot
of a second if these are equal and these
are equal then these two equal right but
this normal here right means that this
guy alpha is the complement of the angle
and vina is the complement of this angle
which is the same angle right so both of
these guys being complementary to the
same angle are also simply now I don't
think you would ever get this question
okay because mainly because it depends
too much specialized language too much
missing I had to look up what some of
these things were okay
however I could describe all of these
angles without using any of the language
that they have I could just give these
things days I could say that's L let's
call that K whatever and then I could
say proof to me that L K whatever is
this this this and you could still do
the same thing okay